l'exposition présente les débuts de
l'archéologie sous napoléon iii
passionné il a financé des fouilles en
france en méditerranée en afrique du
nord mais aussi en italie entre 1861 et
1870 son but était notamment d'écrire un
livre sur jules césar
ces fouilles vont permettre à 11.3 de
recueillir un certain nombre de données
et un certain nombre de matériel
archéologique qui vont lui permettre de
documenter donc la figure de ce général
romain et donc de mieux documenter donc
ça ce sont nous rage des maquettes des
peintures sculptures moulage et
tablettes interactives sont présents
dans l'exposition
tout cela permet de mieux connaître une
autre personnalité de napoléon iii
mais l'objet central de l'exposition
c'est la photographie la photographier
va devenir l'auxiliaire de l'archéologie
elle va ainsi apporter la preuve du réel
jusqu'à présent les fouilleurs est bien
faisait des dessins mais le dessin
pouvait être interprétée dresser des
cartes mais s'écarte être une mauvaise
tout simplement là pour la première fois
la photo va apporter la preuve des dires
la preuve des déclarations dont elle
devient vraiment dominante
vous avez jusqu'au 3 janvier pour venir
découvrir ses oeuvres exposées au musée
d'archéologie nationale